thank you very much everybody
good afternoon today is Good Friday and
the Sunday millions of Christians
celebrate Easter and the resurrection of
Jesus Christ at this holy time we pray
that God will heal the sick and comfort
the heartbroken and bless our heroes as
American families look forward to Easter
we're reminded that our story ends not
in despair but in triumph and renewal
very appropriate isn't it
I'd like to provide Americans an update
on our ongoing efforts in the war
against the invisible enemy before I do
that I'll have a couple of notes the
United States in discussions last night
with Mexico
Saudi Arabia Russia and in dealing with
OPEC nations we are trying to get Mexico
as the expression goes over the barrel
then Mexico it's committing to do a
hundred thousand fewer barrels president
and I spoke last night we have a great
relationship great friendship they're
helping us very much at the border they
have twenty-seven thousand soldiers
Mexican soldiers on our border right now
stopping people from coming into our
country as our wall goes up we're up to
about a hundred and sixty-eight miles of
wall and it's speaking with the
president they have a limit the OPEC
nations have agreed to a different limit
reduction of about 23% so what I thought
I would do and I don't know that it's
going to be accepted we'll find out the
United States will help Mexico along and
they'll reimburse us sometime at a later
date when they're prepared to do so and
we had a great conversation but we'll
find out how that all works out as you
know they're trying to get rid of the
glut of oil there's a tremendous flood
of oil and we don't want anything to
hurt our incredible industry actually
the largest producer in the
now so we don't want anything to hurt
those jobs those great jobs in Texas and
North Dakota and Oklahoma and everywhere
we have a tremendous energy New Mexico
tremendous energy business and we want
to keep those jobs so we're we're
working on and I think eventually it's
gonna work out may work out quicker than
what most people thought possible and
maybe it won't but it'll work out
eventually our experts are monitoring
the data from every part of our country
having to do with the topic that we're
here to discuss in the midst of grief
and pain we're seeing clear signs that
our aggressive strategy is saving
countless lives tremendous progress is
being made although when you look at
some of the numbers I just spoke with
Governor Cuomo with a good talk when you
look at those numbers the numbers of
death people that have died it's so
horrible now on the other side you have
the numbers of beds being used we're
just saying are substantially reduced
that's usually the sign that it's
heading in the downward curve so New
York we know where that is but in the
midst of all this grief in this pain
we're seeing these signs and we're
seeing them very strongly and a lot of
that has to do with the aggressive
strategy in saving so many lives we're
saving so many lives compared to what it
could have been so nobody knows what the
number is but we had a number of a
hundred thousand lives as many as that
is it's impossible to even think of it
and that was the low end with a
tremendous amount of work and a
tremendous amount of you can call it
many different things our people had to
be extremely strong and brave to be able
to put up with what they've put up with
but the minimum if you did this
social distancing and every other aspect
and I think I can say 90% maybe even
more than that we're able to do it the
minimum number was a hundred thousand
lives and I think will be substantially
under that number hard to believe that
if you had 60 thousand you can never be
happy but that's a lot fewer than we
were originally told and thinking so
they said between a hundred and two
hundred and twenty thousand lives on the
minimum side and then up to 2.2 million
lives if we didn't do anything but it
showed just tremendous resolve by the
people of this country so we'll see what
it ends up being but it looks like we're
headed to a number substantially below
the hundred thousand that would be the
low mark and I hope that bears out the
situation in Detroit and New Orleans
appears to be stabilizing Detroit has
really started to go up and now it is
stabilizing in New Orleans is a great
place I have so many friends there they
can't believe what's happening but it's
really stabilized I spoke with the
governor of Louisiana and as you know
we're building them additional beds
right now the Army Corps of Engineers
and FEMA and that is going to be done
and I hope they're not going to be very
well used because I think they've really
I don't think they're going to need them
or certainly not very many of them we
built him a big Hospital of a thousand
beds and now we're we're in the midst of
doing another thousand I don't think
they're gonna be using very many of them
and that's a good thing and there was a
time two weeks ago when we said that's
not gonna be nearly enough we're gonna
have to build more but we wanted to wait
to see and I'm glad we waited it just
looks like they're doing really well
Louisiana and the state of Michigan is
doing really much better than we thought
in Washington State we've made enough
progress that the governor is now able
to return an army field hospital so
we're going to take that hospital we
don't think we need any more hospital
we built thousands of beds all over the
country and we think we're probably not
going to need that hospital anywhere if
we do we're ready to move it to a
different location in New York we're
seeing hospital admissions declining
very substantially as I said a
nationwide the number of new cases per
day is flattening substantially
suggesting that we are near the peak and
our comprehensive strategy is working
overtime our guidelines to slow the
spread or decreasing the rate of new
cases very substantially and will result
in fewer hospital admissions and we're
seeing that it's incredible I think with
with no exceptions it's looking like
it's lower and again that's because of
the people doing what they had to do
great people and and working with
elected representatives and and the
doctors the nurses and everybody I mean
just everybody everybody so so has been
so amazing I was told this morning again
please mention all of those people
working into the grocery stores and it's
true the checkouts and the clerks and
the people that are really and a number
of those people have become infected so
we want to thank them and a shout out to
them with the tireless devotion of
American doctors and nurses and all of
the medical people we've kept our
fatality rate very very low compared to
other countries my administration is
closely monitoring the data and the
viruses impact on our cherished
african-american communities because
they've been hit hard and the Surgeon
General will be sharing more that
information right after we're finished
here he'll be coming up and saying
exactly what's happening cuz it's really
it's very troublesome I will tell you
that I'd also like to provide clarity on
the important point for many Americans
on elective surgeries while we've asked
hospitals to cancel surgeries and
procedures that do not take place
this time just not to do them now the
choice to delay any treatment still
remains between the patient and their
doctor
we're not advising Americans to postpone
medical treatment that their doctor
believes should occur now so it's
different kinds of surgery obviously but
we're really getting to the point where
you can start to think about doing that
surgery if necessary pretty soon I think
pretty soon
yesterday I directed Secretary of
Agriculture Sonny to predict sonny
perdue to expedite aid to American
farmers and secretary Badou will be
using all of the tools at his disposal
to develop a program and very quickly of
at least 16 billion dollars to provide
relief for farmers ranchers and
producers impacted by the corona virus
in this time of crisis we must keep our
supply chains moving from the beginning
right from beginning to end and we're
committed to supporting the amazing men
and women who produce supply I did last
night a statement on social media and I
said I have directed secretary sonny
perdue to expedite help to our farmers
especially to the smaller farmers who
are very very badly hurting right now
I expect secretary Perdue to use all of
the funds and authorities at his
disposal to make sure that our food
supply is stable and safe and our great
farmers are prosperous and continue to
be prosperous we're working very hard to
make sure our food supply chain is sound
and plentiful but we all know that that
begins with our farmers cattlemen
ranchers and producers so we're going to
be working with these small farmers the
big farmers the cattlemen the ranchers
all of the producers we're going to take
care of them we're working with them
right now we have a lot of money that
was put there through our use of tariffs
and other means and we're gonna help out
our farmers and I don't think I'll tell
you I've been helping our farmers for a
couple of years because they were
targeted as you know by China and others
and I think they're very grateful to
what for what we've done on the medical
front the FDA FDA has issued 47
emergency use authorization x' for
advancements and testing new ventilator
designs innovations and personal
protective equipment and experimental
medicines and dr. Hahn's going to be
talking about that we've cut through the
red tape to give doctors and patients
unprecedented freedom to make their own
healthcare decisions
granting access to potential therapies
and drugs since Monday we've deployed
two major shipments of
hydroxychloroquine from our national
stockpile that's going to various cities
and we are also disposing and getting as
quickly as we can portions of it to the
Department of Veterans Affairs and the
Department of Defense and speaking of
the Department of Defense they're going
to be sending us 10 million n95 masks
that they had and we're in great shape
and every way we're in great shape with
ventilators we're in great shape with
protective clothing we have additional
plane loads coming in but we're not
getting any calls from governor's at
this moment I can speak I think for vice
president pence will be talking in a
little while we're getting we're getting
very few calls from from governor's or
anybody else needing anything they're in
great shape for this surge that's coming
in certain areas in particular and
that's a good job you've done a great
job I appreciate it the whole country
appreciates it more than 2-million
corona virus tests have now been
completed and we're conducting
approximately 100,000 more every day
we're also working to bring blood-based
Seri ology tests of the market as
quickly as possible so that Americans
can determine whether or not they have
already had the virus and potentially
have immunity
they have immunity of they've had the
virus a lot of them don't even know if
they've had it sometimes it's brutal you
see the Prime Minister seems to be doing
well now I hope
he had a rough go of it and and still is
but he's doing better and then some
people don't even know they had it it
could be sniffles it could be they don't
feel perfect but they've had it they're
they're the lucky ones the NIH CDC and
FDA are currently validating these
antibody tests to ensure that they are
accurate and they're doing that at
breakneck speed I think we can say that
doctor we're gonna get them approved
very quickly dr. Hahn when validated
we're confident that the production will
scale up to tens of millions of tests
very quickly we're leading the world now
in testing by far and we're gonna keep
it that way
other countries are coming to us and
they're wanting to know about our tests
and can they buy the tests and can they
do whatever they have to do to get the
tests and we're going to make that very
soon we'll be in a position to make that
possible because it's important for them
to have it and we're gonna have an
announcement on the World Health
Organization sometime next week as you
know we give them approximately five
hundred million dollars a year and we're
gonna be talking about that subject next
week we'll have a lot to say about it
we'll hold it every American should be
proud of what our country is achieved in
just a short period of time the US
military is deployed thousands of
personnel to build 23 temporary
hospitals with more than 16,000 beds and
we have the potential to build them
anymore if we needed them we're all
ready to go but I don't think we're
gonna need them which is great fate news
and we built those hospitals in 12
states and the District of Columbia
using the defense production act and we
used it like a hammer a lot of the media
said oh we weren't using it we used it
like a hammer to a point where all we
had to do is say the words and everybody
gave us Mac's and and they've done a
good job they really have done a good
job with few exceptions and we've
harnessed the full power of American
industry to produce ventilators and
other essential supplies
right now we're making thousands of
ventilators many of which we won't need
but we'll use them in our stockpile and
we'll build that up we'll also help
build up the stockpiles which they
should have had in the States and so
we're working with governor's on that
and we'll also help other countries
there are countries that are calling us
for help they need ventilators and there
are no position to build ventilators we
are we have Ford and General Motors and
many many companies are building
ventilators so we're gonna be helping at
a not too distant point we're going to
be helping quite a few of the countries
now we've launched project air bridge to
deliver nearly 300 million pieces of
personal protective equipment from and
around the globe we're also shipping out
60 sterilization systems to ten
different cities that can each sterilize
up to 80,000 masks each day and I'm even
hearing it can go up to 120 thousand
masks a day certain equipment with
certain additions it's a company in Ohio
that makes it a great company great I
hear it's a great product works very
well I asked that question I said how
come we have to buy so many mess why
can't we sterilize the masks that are
being used and the answer was you can in
this case they say up to 20 times so we
can take a mask certain types of masks
the n95
in particular we can sterilize them make
them very clean up to 20 times that's a
great thing in addition we passed the
largest emergency economic relief
package in American history to save the
US economy and protect the American
worker as you know this past week which
was four active days on the stock market
Good Friday today is not is not included
the markets are closed in four days we
had the biggest market increased stock
market increase that we've had in 50
years that tells you that there's a
pent-up demand that tells you they want
to get back there's something good going
to happen I really believe that there's
something very good going to happen we
have to get back so think of it in this
horrible
period this horrible dark period where
this this monster came and and worked
it's horrible horrible spell over the
world 184 countries as of this morning
hundred and eighty four countries we've
done well and I guess the market thinks
we've done well because we had the
biggest stock market increase without
one day we're talking four days instead
of five that we've had in 50 years fifty
years think of that more than fifty
years actually in short the American
people have launched the greatest
mobilization of our society since World
War two deploying every scientific
governmental medical and military
resource to defeat the virus so I want
to just start then with we're gonna
answer questions later we'll have time
if we have a lot of time today a lot of
people are off as they should be Good
Friday but so I'll stick around we'll
answer questions later i want to start
with deborah birx
please dr. Burks and you can go over
some of the numbers we just looked at
and that'd be great thank you very much
different president thank you for
outlining how well we are doing in a
series of metro areas what also has been
encouraging for those of you are
watching
epidemic curves every day and I'm sure
you are and lot watching them in log
phase because that's how Abedini Allah
just like to look at their curves you
can see for the first time that in the
United States were starting to level on
the logarithmic phase like Italy did
about a week ago and so this gives us
great heart that only in specific places
but we're starting to see that change
obviously a lot of that is driven by the
improvement in New York City remember
for a long time they were over 50% of
our cases and 50% of our new cases that
is dramatically changed because of the
impact of what the citizens of New York
and New Jersey and across Connecticut
and now Rhode Island are doing to really
change the course of this pandemic and
really change the trajectory of new
cases we're seeing that
what many states and metro areas were
experienced as to fold and four fold
four fold increases that went to two
fold that now those are going to eight
days between the doubling rate watching
this every day gives us hope across
these metro areas from New York and New
Jersey and all through Denver and of
course through New Orleans we still see
cases occurring in the Boston area and
in Chicago but their rate of increase
seems to be stabilizing and we really
want to call out the work of the mayors
of Baltimore and the district and
Philadelphia who have really brought all
of their health health experts together
and working with their communities are
starting to really change the curves in
those areas what we're seeing is we're
united in social distancing and that's
been very encouraging to all of us and
it should be encouraging to the health
care providers that are on the front
line many of which are serving our
Americans with such dignity and respect
and ensuring that everybody gets optimal
care and as the president noted our
mortality in the United States is
significantly less than many of the
other countries when you correct them
for our population and that is really
solely the work of our health our
frontline health care providers and so
working with you can really hopefully
you get the theme today that we are
incredibly proud of our public health
leaders at the city level at the state
level at the federal level who are
working together to really change the
course of this pandemic working with
their citizens and their communities to
make these changes and the American
public who have really taken all of this
to heart and stayed home I know last
week we really asked a lot of people in
the Washington and Baltimore area to
consolidate not go out frequently to
grocery stores or pharmacies you can
really see that that's having a huge
impact so it's really about the
encouraging signs that we see but as
encouraging as they are we have not
reached the peak and so every day we
need to continue to do what we did
yesterday and the week before
and the week before that because that's
what in the end is going to take us up
across the peak and down the other side
we continue to really applaud the work
of California and Washington State and
Oregon we're learning from all three of
those states from their public health
officials about how they were able to
keep the virus from ever becoming
logarithmic and I think that's an
important lesson for all of us on how
they did that what the timing was in
case we ever have to face this issue in
the future thank you mr. president thank
you very much mr. president
so again just keeping on the theme that
dr. Burks had had mentioned this is the
end of the week
that famous week that we spoke about
last weekend in which we what actually
was predicted to happen happened was
starting to see the leveling off in
there coming down that dr. Burks had
mentioned but it's important to remember
that this is not the time to feel that
since we have made such important
advance in the sense of success of the
mitigation that we need to be pulling
back at all I was actually hearkened by
the fact that we've been talking about
the New York New Jersey New Orleans and
other areas where they have really big
spikes but there's other parts of the
country in the middle parts of the
country where their concern to make sure
they don't get those spikes and I really
want to salute the governors of states
throughout the entire United States but
particularly in the central part of the
country because the governor is after
you see us in these press conferences
and I've had calls over the last several
days from several of the governors you
know from Nebraska Iowa South Dakota
Utah just about an hour and a half ago I
spoke with the governors of Arkansas and
Wyoming who are really committed to make
sure that they don't get into the
situation where they're gonna have
spikes in their state and they're doing
the kinds of things that they don't get
recognized because people don't talk
about them much but we have a big
country we have 50 states and it's not
only the big cities so if we're gonna
pull out of this we're gonna pull out of
it in the big cities and we're gonna
pull out it in those areas that aren't
as densely populated and I just want to
give a shout out to them they're doing
an extraordinary job
I was really Pleasant I wouldn't say
surprised because I expected of this
country but to hear what they're doing
and the commitment that they're putting
in to making sure that we don't have the
kinds of situations that we've
experienced unfortunately in other areas
this is very important I just want to
close by one of the things something I
mentioned yesterday and the day before
that there are a lot of candidate
interventions that are going into
clinical trials for those of you are
interested in it I recommend you go to
clinical trials.gov and you'll see the
design of a clinical trial and you see
that many of them are the randomized
control trials that are the really gold
standard of how you find out whether
something really is safe and effective
and as the weeks and months said it'll
probably be months sometime in the
summer we'll start to see which are
working which are not and to focus on
those that are we developing and we'll
working I'll be happy to answer
questions later thank you
Thank You mr. president
the White House Task Force has been very
focused on increasing the supply of
personal protective equipment for our
great providers I was one of those
providers a few months ago and I can
tell you nothing is more important than
making sure they have what they need so
in order to increase the supply of n95
masks FDA has worked with industry and
has now authorized two companies who
will supply machines to sterilize n95
masks Admiral of check and FEMA are
purchasing on behalf of US government 60
sterilization machines as mentioned by
the President and they will be
positioned around the country to
increase the amount of supply of n95
masks each machine will be able to
sterilize 80,000 95 masks and 95 mass
per day and we hope to actually increase
that further the vice president and the
White House Task Force challenged us
yesterday and we responded as a team FDA
issued revised guidance regarding the
laundering of gowns because gowns are
another issue in terms of supply that
we're looking forward on this is not
something that normally happens around
the country but issued this guidance
it's on our website now at Ft
so there's information about how
hospitals can do that to increase the
supply we've heard concerns that maybe
hospitals might not want to do that
because of regulations and I can happy
to tell you that administrator Verma and
I have worked on this certified
providers and suppliers who follow FDI
FDA guidance as posted on the website
will be compliant with Medicare and
Medicaid requirements and then finally
last week FDA it provided guidance to
manufacturers on manufacturing
specifications for cloth gowns this is
another attempt to increase the number
of gowns typically it's plastic or other
types of materials and this guidance if
followed can be used by manufacturers to
actually make these gowns and no further
regulatory red tape will be unnecessary
they can go into circulation thank you
Thank You mr. president good afternoon
everyone I started off the week talking
about the challenges that lie ahead and
I want to finish the week just by
reiterating what you've heard
mitigation works it definitively and
quantitatively is working and I want to
say thank you to America for your
efforts to help flatten the curve and to
save lies but at the president's
Direction yesterday I met with 2,000
Hispanic leaders from their communities
in today
and the vice president led a phone call
that I was on with hundreds of
african-american leaders including the
Reverend Jesse Jackson including Derrick
Johnson of the n-double a-c-p
including the National Medical
Association and the black Nurses
Association to talk about some of the
alarming trends were observing regarding
the impact of kovat 19 on communities of
color and you've heard the stats in New
York City
Hispanics represents the majority of
deaths in Milwaukee County blacks are
25% of the population but almost 50% of
the cases and 75% of the deaths so
what's going on well it's alarming but
it's not surprising that people of color
have a greater burden of chronic health
conditions african-americans and Native
Americans
excuse me develop high blood pressure at
much younger ages and so that's likely
to be on
control and does greater harm to their
organs Puerto Ricans have higher rates
of asthma and black boys are three times
as likely to die of asthma as their
white counterparts as a matter of fact
I've been carrying around an inhaler in
my pocket for 40 years out of fear of
having a fatal asthma attack and I hope
that showing you this inhaler shows
little kids with asthma all across the
country that they can grow up to be
Surgeon General one day but I more
immediately share it so that everyone
knows it doesn't matter if you look fit
if you look young you were still at risk
for getting and spreading and dying from
coronavirus the chronic burden of
medical ills is likely to make people of
color especially less resilient to the
ravages of kovin 19 and if possibly in
fact likely that the burden of social
ills is also contributing social
distancing and teleworking we know are
critical and you've heard dr. Brooks and
dr. Feld she talked about how they
prevent the spread of corona virus yet
only one in five African Americans and
one in six Hispanics has a job that lets
them work from home people of color are
more likely to live in densely packed
areas and in multi-generational housing
which situations which create higher
risk for spread of a highly contagious
disease like kovat 19 we tell people to
wash their hands but a study showed 30
percent of the homes on Navajo Nation
don't have running water so how are they
going to do that and some rate people of
color experienced both more likely
exposure to Cove in 19 and increase
complications from it but let me be
crystal clear we do not think people of
color are biologically or genetically
predisposed to get kovin 19 there is
nothing inherently wrong with you but
they are socially predisposed to
coronavirus dispose of exposure and to
have a higher incidence of the very
diseases that put you at risk for severe
complications of coronavirus but as the
vice president shared on the call this
morning this history and I want you to
hear me say this it does not have to be
our nation's future we're taking steps
now in the midst of the kovat 19
pandemic to reach protect and strengthen
all communities impacted by this disease
and especially our communities of color
more details will be forthcoming but we
are actively working as the vice
president and the CDC director laid out
today
data collection targeted outreach to
communities of color
and increasing financial employment
education housing social and health
supports so that everybody has an equal
chance to be healthy and I want to close
by saying that while your state and
local health department's and those of
us in public service are working day and
night to help stop the spread of covin
19 and protect you regardless of your
color your creed or your geography I
need you to know you are not helpless
and it's even more important than in
communities of color we adhere to the
taskforce guidelines to slow the spread
stay at home if possible if you must go
out maintain six feet of distance
between you and everyone else and wear a
mask if you're going to be within six
feet of others wash your hands more
often than you ever dreamed possible
avoid alcohol tobacco and drugs and call
your friends and family check in on your
mother she wants to hear from you right
now and speaking of mothers we need you
to do this if not for yourself then for
your abuela do it for your granddaddy do
it for your Big Mama do it for your
pop-pop we need you to understand
especially in communities of color we
need you to step up and help stop the
spread so that we can protect those who
are most vulnerable this epidemic is a
tragedy but it will be all the more
tragic if we fail to recognize and
address the disproportionate impact of
kovat 19 and an array of other diseases
and risk factors on communities of color
the task force in this administration
are determined not to let that happen
the president the vice president has
said we will not let that happen we
can't fix these issues overnight but I
promise you we will work with your
communities to quickly and meaningfully
move the needle in the right direction
nothing less than the fate of our
families and friends my family and
friends depends on it
Thank You mr. president today the White
House coronavirus task force met and and
heard from the president the gratitude
that he and I and I know all the
American people feel for all the
dedicated workers at FEMA HHS US Public
Health Service FDA and all those that
are literally working on your behalf
around the clock to partner with States
to partner with local health officials
and mr. president allow me to add my my
thanks and admiration to all of the
entire team here at the federal level on
this Good Friday we we remember those
who've lost their lives to the
coronavirus we remember their families
our dedicated health care workers and
our first responders and we do well on
this special day for Christians across
this country to remember them in our
prayers but as you just heard from dr.
Burks and from the experts it's also a
good day to remember that Good Friday is
always followed by Easter Sunday and
there is hope there's hope in this
moment that thanks to what the American
people are doing every day adhering to
the president's coronavirus guidelines
for America thanks to the fact that
Americans are listening to state and
local leaders and putting the health of
their family members and neighbors first
we're getting there America we're making
progress but it's imperative that we all
continue to implement all of the
guidance in the 30 days to slow the
spread as a certain general just
attested at the president's direction we
engaged more than 400 leaders in the
african-american community today and
allow me to express my appreciation for
their leadership and their efforts in
communicating to African Americans and
other minority populations some of the
unique challenges that those communities
face in the midst of this epidemic and
the CDC as the Surgeon General said is
working on not only studying the issue
but very rapidly issue
new guidance and we'll be communicating
that new guidance to all of those great
leaders on the subject of testing and
supplies the president gave a great
amount of detail more than 2.1 million
tests have been performed we continue to
work very very closely with FDA and
suppliers around the country to expand
the ability of testing and you just
heard dr. Han reflect on the fact very
soon we will have an antibody test the
Americans will be able to take to
determine whether they ever had the
corona virus I spoke today to the
governor of Colorado jared Polis we've
been in contact with Senator Cory
Gardner about an outbreak at a a
particular meatpacking facility in the
Colorado area at this time our team is
working with the governor and working
with the senator to ensure that we flowe
testing resources at this point there
are some 14 people hospitalized maybe 2
to 300 of the work force have been
impacted and we spoke about providing
those resources this weekend I want to
encourage people in Colorado that we
will we will work to support that effort
but I also want to emphasize that all
the people that are working in food
supply
I'm from farmers to meat packers to
distributors to truckers to grocers
continue to have our gratitude as
President Trump said just a few moments
ago on supplies more than five billion
have been obligated to the state's 29600
National Guard have been activated and
at the president's Direction more than
4,700 active duty military personnel
have been deployed medical military
personnel in nine states focusing on the
areas of the most significant epidemic
airbridge 26 flights have been completed
four flights are scheduled to arrive
today bringing a quarter million gowns
25 million pairs of gloves 54 more
flights are scheduled literally bringing
in supplies from around the world now
finally let me say as we go into this
very special weekend into Easter service
I know I speak on behalf of of the
president when I say how grateful we are
to all of the churches that have been
there and their ministries have been
working under great difficulty to
continue to provide for the needs of
your members there have been there have
been food drives there had been phone
calls and ministry has continued and we
are grateful for the role on this holy
week that our churches our synagogues
and all of our houses of worship have
played on their behalf allow me to
remind you that even if you're not in
the pew this Easter Sunday if you are
able it's still a good idea to give
because those ministries continue to go
forward and we encourage you we
encourage you to continue to support
them we also want to say very
respectfully to all of the all the
church communities around this country
and all the places of worship to
continue to heed the guidelines issued
in the president's coronavirus
guidelines for America we know it's
difficult and this time of year
particularly mr. president to avoid
gatherings of more than 10 but we're
grateful that so many churches
synagogues and places of worship have
done just that and we urge you to
continue to do it and to my Christian
brothers and sisters across the country
let me encourage you with the words we
should all remember that jesus said
wherever two or more are gathered there
he is also and so you can worship you
can celebrate Easter and know that
you'll be blessed in so doing and you'll
be serving the nation Thank You mr.
president
thank you
okay it's good Friday let's be nice okay
let's be real nice can you clarify a
little bit of what the US offered to
Mexico in order to agree to that oil
deal and then also go into detail about
what you spoke about on oil with
personally that's what all of the OPEC
nations met and others and they're all
agreeing to cut back because there's a
tremendous blood we don't even we're
filling up our strategic reserves we
don't even have room to store it in fact
they're using ships to store oil it's
there's never been anything like this it
was being over produced to start off
with and then you had the virus and that
took off 40 percent right there so we
have there's a glut of oil like nobody's
ever seen before
it's good in many ways and depending on
where you are who you are it's bad we
have a tremendous energy business with
hundreds of thousands of jobs we're
doing great number one in the world so
they all got together and they said
we're going to cut it because we have to
get rid of this tremendous supply now
the good news is gasoline prices I'm
seeing 90 cents 85 cents in different
parts of the country a gallon nobody's
ever seen that I guess you have to go
back to the 1950s for that the big large
dollar bills remember you don't remember
you're too young but the fact that you
have to go back a long ways to see it so
there's some good the airlines are
trying to come back having low fuel
costs is good for them and are the
reasons steel manufacturing but a lot of
the steel goes to building what we do
for the oil and engineering firms so you
know that's a that's a double-edged
sword but it's it's we want to keep our
energy we want to remain independent we
will remain independent I think
regardless but we want to get rid of
this tremendous overflow there's no
place to even store it so the OPEC
nations met they've been meeting and you
know I've hated OPEC over the years
absolutely hated them but obviously it
broke down and we potentially have years
worth of supply a long time before it
ever can catch up even if they do reduce
it and they agreed but Mexico didn't
agree it was one of the few countries
that didn't agree this is OPEC plus
these are OPEC plus countries outside
you understand
and Mexico didn't agree and I understand
the president very well he has a level
when he came in and he wanted to keep it
at that level oil is important for
Mexico the problem is and I explained it
very strongly you know you're gonna be
selling it for $5 or $10 a barrel so in
the end it's bad but he did have some
political difficulty with it frankly and
I understand that too and it's a small
amount for us it's a large amount for
Mexico but it's a very small amount for
the United States being the biggest
producer so I agreed to pick up some of
the slack so he was going to reduce it
by a hundred thousand barrels reduces
output by a hundred thousand barrels and
I was gonna pick up the slack and they
would make it up to us at a later date
they would make up what we're doing at a
later date it could be in a different
form and I don't know whether or not
that's going to be from Mexico was
acceptable I don't know whether or not
that's going to be acceptable to the
other oil-producing nations we'll find
out but it's something that would
certainly be acceptable to me to get it
over the back so Mexico's going to
reduce by a hundred thousand barrels and
that would mean that they're 250 to 300
barrels short we'd make up the
difference they would reimburse us at a
later date okay
by cutting some US production now the
u.s. production has already been cut
because we're a market driven economy
and and oil is very market driven
they've been cutting oil all over the
place we're cutting it back and what
does it mean really it means we have it
in the ground we can use it now we have
a lot of we have a lot of ground with a
lot of oil in it when I think we're
number one in that too we're probably
number one especially with n were as you
know I got n were approved in Alaska
that's one of the biggest finds anywhere
in the world so when you add it all up I
think we're probably number one even in
what we have under we're very lucky we
were we grew up in a land that was rich
in a lot of ways but it's also rich
because it has a lot of oil underneath
oil and gas and as you know natural gas
LNG is all over the country now at a
very low price and our carbon our
atmosphere our
the level of environmental cleanliness
is that it's all-time best right now
all-time best because we are using a lot
of natural gas but we have many forms of
energy including some of the newer forms
that people want to see us go to we have
a lot of different forms of energy we're
number one in the world we want to keep
it that way
so we're helping Mexico out we will be
reimbursed in a form sometime in the
future this resin I'll ask you about the
new federal projections in a moment but
first today you tweeted the invisible
enemy will soon be in full retreat given
its invisible without widespread testing
how would you know well I think that
we're going to have it in retrieved with
it will be today no tomorrow no but it
will be at a certain point in the
not-too-distant future it will be gun
testing specifically no no because
people aren't going to go to the
hospital people aren't going to get sick
you're gonna know that with that but
we're going to do very substantial
testing we're doing more testing right
now than any other country in the world
by far and if you would like to have
that question answer I'll have the
professional answer it Deborah perhaps
you could come up we are doing
tremendous testing but you'll know
you're gonna know before anybody because
you're gonna see nobody's getting sick
anymore
it will be gone and it won't be that
much longer good ask about the
projections out there thanks mr.
president
Thank You mr. president so the testing I
want to re-emphasize about what kind of
testing we're talking about this is RN a
diagnostic testing that is the platform
that was built to respond to this
epidemic it is the same platform that we
utilize for HIV viral loads and so many
HIV clients have also given up their
space on the machines to have these
tests run for all of Americans this
assay is complicated it's not like an
assay that you have for your other
diseases your strep test or other
diseases like that this is a very
complicated assay that requires I'm a
lot of technical oversight and it's part
of the reason why not all a hundred
percent our machines are running at full
capacity but we had great discussion
with the lab directors about that every
day more are brought online and so but I
think we have to create expect
patience of what the daily test rates
will be last year we probably did three
million HIV viral loads or four million
HIV viral loads as a country we've done
over to almost 2.2 million in four weeks
so this is unprecedented and what we
have to do I think that's why we're
working very hard for two pieces and I
want to make sure that people understand
testing is just part of our strategy the
other part of the strategy has to be
this syndromic and influenza like
illness where there's an alert to an
illness and so that we're surveying
where we know the most vulnerable cases
have appeared in the great call that I
had with the mayors and with the health
officials yesterday and mayor's today a
lot in the rural areas their primary and
as it was in Washington in California
was it the nursing homes so the the
issue is to build a testing strategy
that speaks to our strengths of laser
focusing a strategic approach to testing
when we know what our volumes are and
they increase every day but we have to
be realistic about what the volumes will
be a week two weeks three weeks from now
and combine that with strategic
surveillance so that we're testing
symptomatic people and their contacts
very quickly to go back to contact
tracing utilizing our complete strategy
and I think we're very much interested
in it's why the president three weeks
ago really put us on getting an antibody
test and I think I called from the
podium for our University colleagues and
unit and hospitals to begin analyze
abased test because that's a blood draw
but we really wanted a finger prick to
make it easy and deployable that's
what's being worked on now of course we
don't want to promise until we have it
because I think we deserve that the
American people deserve that to have a
test that is efficient to let people
know who's been positive for immunity
that's critical to epidemiologists and
public health officials to know what the
penetrance of a virus was into a
community when all you're seeing are the
serious cases and testing the most
symptomatic
and so that's a question that we still
have is this the tip of the iceberg or
is this half the iceberg or
three-quarters of the iceberg what we
have seen to date and we have I just
want to complete the thought by saying
in the areas where we had an outbreak
these large metros Louisiana Denver
Detroit Chicago New York New Jersey but
per capita we've done more tests than
any other place in the world that was
intentional we focused the tests where
with a need was the greatest and the
burden of disease the greatest and now
we're trying to really see how
strategically that very valuable
resource can be utilized around the
countries to create a mosaic of testing
combined with surveillance about the new
federal projections there's new
reporting today the new federal
projections - just let me ask you about
the new federal projections that suggest
lifting the 30-day shelter-in-place
orders would lead to a spike in
infections have you seen those new
projections from your Department of
Homeland Security and HHS it would if
they haven't seen I guess you're seeing
they were I guess they leaked it to NBC
they did we could toss that's being or
nobody seen it and they're the ones that
do it it's from the HHS and DOJ
I haven't seen that so court on that
that's okay I still haven't seen I've
been here all day so what I think what
they're talking about is that whenever
you pull back you would expect that you
might start seeing cases and what we've
been talking about what dr. Burks has
just mentioned is that when you see that
that's where you want your resources to
be able to very efficiently in real-time
identify isolate and contact trace so
don't let anyone get any false ideas
that when we decide at a proper time
when we
gonna be relaxing some of the
restrictions there's no doubt you're
gonna see cases I would be so surprised
if we did not see cases the question is
how you respond to them I think that's
what they were referring to question mr.
president should Americans have to
decide between staying healthy and going
back to work look I think we're going to
do both we're gonna go back to work and
we're gonna stay healthy and staying
healthy is also a proportion if you look
at what we're doing we're looking at a
date we hope we're gonna be able to
fulfill a certain date but we're not
doing anything until we know that this
country is going to be healthy we don't
want to go back and start doing it over
again even though it would be in a
smaller scale yeah Jeff go ahead
President of Mexico said that you would
agree that the US would cut production
by 250,000 barrels per day is that what
you agreed to yes we would which we've
already done by the way but we would
agree to a reduction could they would
agree to do something to compensate us
in the future
didn't you make any assurances to Saudi
Arabia that you the United States would
not bail out oil drillers here we didn't
discuss that with Saudi Arabia we just
discussed the numbers and we discussed
who's opposed and who's not and pretty
much everybody is in favor of it because
they're getting clobbered they're all
getting clobbered all of those countries
are having problems if you look at Saudi
Arabia that's their source of income
primary source of income by far so they
want to do it Russia wants to do it the
OPEC nations want to do it they all want
to do it so we'll see what happens
there's a difference between wanting to
do it and doing it yeah go ahead
oh yeah
that is really good your administration
has placed a 15 million dollar bounty on
Venezuela's nicolas maduro
and we have news this morning that
President Xi is talking with Nicolas
Maduro
expressing his financial support for
Maduro so two questions one have you
discussed with dr. sheet or President Xi
you're the US policy on Maduro and who
are what is how does it affect us policy
that takes place I have not spoken to
President Xi of China about Venezuela
about that aspect of Venezuela but if
that took place we will not be happy
okay I will know I'm concerned about
everything that's why don't sleep a lot
I get myself concerned about everything
but I would not be happy about that go
ahead president getting back to Peter's
question a variation of that question
your doctors who are gathered here seem
to be in doubt as to whether or not the
country could reopen on May the 1st if
they come to you before May the 1st and
say the country is not ready are huge
parts of the country are not ready to
reopen on May the 1st will you listen to
them I think they're actually surprised
I have great respect for these people
all of them and others that are working
with us I have great respect for this
group in fact I told Tony Faraci I said
why don't you move to New York run
against AOC you will win easily so he
decided that he's not going to do that
ok my kid by the way they you know that
so some of your allies have been bashing
these doctors would you tell them to cut
it out I can only say this I have
tremendous respect for these people and
we've done very well and when you look
at us compared to others we're a big
nation when you look at us compared to
others when you see how we've taken
testing from a broken system that I
inherited to having the best tests that
anyone's made anywhere in the world and
other countries are calling us wanting
to use our technology I have great
respect for these people I'm never
saying bad about this
if they come back to you service age
before May the first we can't open on
May the first do you listen I would you
remember there's I know I understand the
other side of the argument very well
because I look at both sides of an
argument I will listen to them very
carefully though please go ahead Thank
You mr. president
you may have seen this but JP Morgan
came out with a forecast about GDP
growth in the second quarter we're
saying a 40% decline in the second
quarter of this year do your economic
advisors share that view um I think my
economic advisors are interested in the
third quarter and really the fourth
quarter and I think we have a chance to
do record fourth quarter numbers because
there's a tremendous pent-up demand and
you see it this week I mean what reason
would there be other than faith in us
and in this country faith in this group
and me and your vice president and
everybody governor's perhaps you can add
them into it also what reason would
there be for in a shortened week four
days instead of five to have the biggest
stock market gain in over 50 years so I
think that you know to me there's a sign
hey look with all we've been down I mean
we've we've never been hit I don't know
has this country ever been hit like this
probably not 1917 but that was different
and it was a different time and frankly
Europe took the brunt of it we didn't
but it was a terrible time also but
probably never been hit like this right
somebody was saying in fact I was
speaking with Governor Cuomo about it
because we were in New York City a place
we loved New York State with the World
Trade Center and that was approximately
3,000 people
well we've doubled that in this same
area we've doubled that more than double
it substantially more and it's obviously
going you know we had our highest number
yesterday and the day before okay with
all of this news what would lead you to
believe that we're gonna have the best
stock market week shortened wig in 50
years almost broke the all-time record
you know that is that's a pent-up two
men now that's my opinion the other
thing is we're doing tremendous stimulus
plans and despite what you read it you
know
this back and forth but we are getting
along with the Democrats they want to
see something happen we have to help our
workers we have to help our small
businesses we have to help we have to
help our restaurants I think
deductibility will be great for
entertainment restaurants all of that
look I think with the stimulus with the
people with what we've got going with
all of the things we're going to be
meeting with the airlines over the
weekend we have a great plan for the
airlines we've got to keep the airlines
going you know it's never been a great
business but it's a very vital business
for the country we're gonna be meeting
with Boeing we're gonna be meeting with
a lot of companies that are great
companies and were great companies a
short while ago I mean we can't let
anything happen to Boeing it's you know
got so much potential you talk about
potential can anything have more
potential than that so we have a lot of
very exciting things taking place we
have tremendous plans we have tremendous
stimulus and I think we have a chance to
do really well so this quarter isn't the
quarter I'm looking at the third quarter
we start to think about it and I think
fourth quarter is going to be at a level
that maybe we haven't seen before I
think our country with the stimulus with
all that we've been through we've
learned a lot don't forget we've learned
about pandemics and epidemics we've
learned a tremendous amount and with all
that we've learned as an example we're
making ventilators we have thousands of
them being delivered in the very near
future we have countries calling us can
we have ventilators that would have been
an unthinkable call I'd be I wouldn't
know what to say they have people dying
but we needed them for ourselves we have
plenty before the surge in New York they
need far fewer hospital rooms or far
fewer hospital beds in particular than
we thought
and I have to say dr. Brooks told me
that four weeks ago six weeks ago
remember you said that number is too
high we don't need that money and based
on what she said and others we did what
we had to do we actually gave the
maximum we built Javits we sent the ship
in we then made the ship kovat because
you know there weren't a lot
people on the roads you didn't have the
accidents that we thought other
unrelated acts and there's nobody
driving you know normally have a lot of
car accidents you have a lot of
motorcycle accidents you have people
going to the house we didn't have that
we had almost none of it so a lot of
things have happened I think we have a
chance to be stronger than before I
really do
I think the stimulus is very important
what we're doing I think it's very very
important please go ahead press advanced
key about credit and debt as well many
American individuals families have had
to tap their credit cards during this
period and businesses have had to draw
down their credit lines are you
concerned mr. president that that may
hobble the US economy all of that debt
number one and number two would you
suggest to credit card companies to
reduce their fees during this time
well it's something that we've already
suggested we're talking to them business
interruption insurance I'd like to see
these insurance companies you know you
have people that have paid when I was in
private I had business interruption when
my business was interrupted through a
hurricane or whatever it may be I have
business where I had it I didn't always
have it sometimes I had it sometimes I
have a lot of different companies but if
I had it I'd expect to be paid you have
people I speak mostly to the restaurant
tours where they have a restaurant
they've been paying for 25 30 35 years
business interruption they've never
needed it all of a sudden they need it
and I'm very good at reading language I
did very well in these subjects okay
and I don't see the word pandemic
mentioned now some cases it is it's an
exclusion but in a lot of cases I don't
see it I don't see reference and they
don't want to pay up I would like to see
the insurance companies pay if they need
to pay if it's fair and they know what's
fair and I know what's fair I can tell
you very quickly but business
interruption insurance that's getting a
lot of money to a lot of people and
they've been paying for years you know
sometimes they just started paying but
you have people that have never asked
for business interruption insurance and
they've been paying a lot of money for a
lot of years for the privilege of having
it and then when they finally need it
the insurance company says we're not
going to give it
we can't let that happen please good on
March 6 you said anyone who wants tests
can get a test now you're saying that
there that you would be open to
reopening the government without having
a National Testing system how do you
square those two statements given that
there's still issues with testing going
forward and how can you tell people
there's not a lot and it's a good
question there's not a lot of issues
with testing certain sections of the if
we go to Iowa we go to Nebraska we go an
interest in the Idaho is very
interesting because they had a few
breakout small breakouts but they're
very very capable states and they're big
distances a lot of land a lot of opening
you don't need testing there you know
where you have a state with a small
number of cases some states with almost
none
West Virginia hung in for a long time as
you know with none for a long time so
when you have that you don't need
testing you don't have to test every
person in the state of Iowa as an
example you don't have to test every
single person to say let's open up and
let's get the tractors moving and let's
get the corn and let's open up all of
the different things they do in that
great state you don't need that and with
that being said if there's a little hot
corner someplace we'll be testing but I
think Deborah speaks to this very well
the same thing in New York that's what
we talked to Governor Cuomo about this
morning we have the Abbott test which is
very quick and very easy goes very fast
then we have a lesser test that we
talked about where we can talk about a
larger area but you're going to know so
we're going to do testing but you don't
need to test 325 to 350 million people
because double one it's unnecessary vast
numbers vast areas of our country don't
need this I think you agree with me on
that you just don't need it now we have
certain hot spots so Louisiana's a hot
spot New York's a hot spot Detroit's a
hot spot and then you have certain areas
in certain hot spots that you have to
even go more so and we're doing all of
that remember this
more testing than any country in the
world and we have the best test and we
developed this over a very short period
of time for you mr. president we know
that these health disparities have
existed for a long time among
african-americans Latinos and other
people of color why did the
administration possibly have a plan
directed at those communities to prevent
high death rates knowing that the health
disparities were there well we do have a
plan and one of the things I'm most
proud about is what I've been able to do
for the african-american community the
lowest job numbers in the history of our
country this was just before the virus
came well I'm just saying because you
know this has been here for three weeks
right so just before African American
community had the lowest unemployment
the best employment numbers more African
American people and communities have
been thriving if you look at our
opportunity zones and what we did Tim
Scott who is fantastic a fantastic
senator came to me Opportunity Zones
more jobs for African Americans than
ever before better health care that
they've ever had before all of these
things the Surgeon General spoke to it
and he spoke to it I thought really
brilliantly I found it very interesting
what he said and I'd love you to come up
and answer the second part of a question
because I think you're you would do it a
much better job than I would please
thank you I have a quick question for
you you you said that african-americans
and Latino should avoid alcohol drugs in
tobacco
you said do it free arm well I'd do it
for Big Mama and pop pop there are some
people I really going to language and
the idea that you're saying behaviors
might be leading to these high death
rates could you talk about whether or
not people could you I guess have a
response or people who might be offended
by the language they used well I use
that language because that's the
language I've been meeting with the
n-double-a-cp
with the National Medical Association
with others actually talked with with
Derek Johnson multiple times this week
the head of the n-double a-c-p
and we need targeted outreach to the
african-american community and I use the
language that is used in my
family I have a Puerto Rican
brother-in-law I call my granddaddy
granddaddy I have relatives who call
their there their grandparents Big Momma
so that was not meant to be offensive
that's the language that we use and that
I use and we need to continue to target
our outreach to those communities it is
critically important that they
understand it's not just about them and
I was very clear about that it's not
just about what you do but you also are
not helpless we need to do our part at
the federal level we need people to do
their parts at the state level and we
need everyone black brown white whatever
color you are to follow the president's
guidelines the coronavirus guidelines
and do their part because when I talked
to the n-double-a-cp
and three weeks ago it's important to
note that one of the things they asked
me was can you help dispel the myths in
this community that that people actually
can't get coronavirus if they're black
that would emit that without there
that's actually very important for us to
squash here it's especially important
for people who were at risk and with
comorbidities but yes all Americans so
thank you and I will clarify that all
Americans need to avoid these substances
at all times I put out a smoking
cessation report in January I put out a
advisory against youth and pregnant
women using marijuana last year and that
was not directed towards any one race
that's everybody needs to do everything
they can to be as healthy as possible at
this critical time you did it
beautifully yeah I can't do it any
better than that and I I know
Jeron personally and I can just testify
that he made no not even a hint of being
offensive at all with that comment I
thought that was appropriate Thanks our
Surgeon General I just hope nobody
steals him and he goes to one of these
big companies for a fortune don't leave
us
right don't leave us to release he's
doing a great you are happy and you're
doing a great job and everybody
everybody tells me that too so we
appreciate it
please thank you so Google and Apple
will have announced that they are
jointly enabling contact tracing on
their mobile phone operating systems and
this is something if you would consider
or maybe the top freedoms problems and a
lot of other things is something we're
gonna look at it certainly and we know
they've done that and it's highly it's
very new new technology it's very
interesting but a lot of people worry
about it in terms of a person's freedom
we're gonna take a look at that a very
strong look at it will let you know
pretty soon Brandon oh yes please
so can you explain why it is appropriate
in the middle of a pandemic to be
talking about cutting or eliminating
funding for the World Health
Organization well we're gonna talk about
the whu-oh next week in great detail I
didn't want to do it today
Good Friday I didn't want to do it
before Easter I also didn't want to do
it before we have all the facts but over
the years many years we've been paying
them from 300 to 500 and even were
million dollars a year China has been
paying them less than 40 over the years
so we're paying them more than 10 times
more than China and they are very very
china centric as I said during the week
China centric China always seems the bet
to get the better of the the argument
and I don't like that I really don't
like that I don't think that's
appropriate I don't think it's fair to
the American people and you know I'd
tell that to President Xi I'd tell that
to dr. Ted Rose I spoke to him one time
I I think he's a very nice man I liked
him but we're gonna be talking about
that next week in great detail we're
looking at it very very closely we want
to make sure money is properly spent but
again why is the United States paying
500 million dollars a year
that's a lot and why is okay that's a
lot and why is China paying last year
this year 42 million dollars but
generally under 40 so it's in the 30s so
we're at 500 450 to
400 401 different amounts different
years and they're at 40 38 36 35 32 31
no no but but you have to ask yourself
that question and then the answer always
turns out to be in China's favor well I
have the same thing with the world trade
isn't it interesting world trade so we
have world health and we have world
trade so we have the World Trade
Organization and until I came along we
were losing cases so many cases it was
ridiculous we were always losing these
cases you know was every case and now
we're winning cases we just won seven
billion dollars because they know I'm
not gonna put up with it
China has been unbelievably taken
advantage of us and other countries you
know further since they're considered a
developing nation I said well then make
us a developing nation too they get big
advantages because they're developing
nation India a developing nation the
United States is the big developed
nation well we have plenty of
development to do okay and now we're
winning cases because they know that if
we're not treated fairly I'm gonna pull
out now you never heard this before cuz
nobody ever talked about the World Trade
Organization but the World Trade
Organization has treated us very
unfairly but they know I'm not gonna put
up with it because all of these
countries are taking advantage of the
United States now in the courts and the
court system we're not approving new
judges over the last year we're not
going to approve them and Bob light
house is working very hard on that but
we had always a minority position
meaning numbers of judges so we'd have a
minority number of judges I said how do
you win with a minority number of judges
but all of a sudden we're winning and
the reason we're winning is they know if
they don't treat us properly and we won
seven billion dollars just this very
recently and the money is pouring in and
we want other cases too with what a lot
of cases but you know from covering it I
know you know that the United States was
taken advantage of by the World Trade
Organization and by the way speaking of
China if you look at the history of
it was only since they went into the
World Trade Organization that they
became a rocket ship with their economy
they were flatlined for years and years
frankly for many many decades and it was
only when they came into the World Trade
Organization that they became a rocket
ship because they took advantage of all
there was I'm not even blaming him I'm
saying how stupid were the people that
stood here and allowed it to happen but
we don't allow that to happen and if
they don't treat us fairly we'll leave
but now we're starting to win cases how
about somebody new for a change come on
school districts are closing across the
country Florida governor Rhonda's Santas
has not ruled out closing for opening
out schools in May saying that many kids
are not vulnerable to this disease do
you agree with that assessment and you
believe that schools would you recommend
that schools open up and to those states
that have it well I have a lot of
confidence in Rhonda scientists a lot of
faith in Rhonda Sanchez to make the
right decision he's doing a great job as
governor Ron de santis I had read where
he's thinking about opening up the
schools earlier than the date at the end
of the month I'd have to look at the
numbers but again you know I like to
allow governor's to make decisions
without overruling them because from a
constitutional standpoint that's the way
it should be done if I disagreed I would
overrule a governor and I have that
right to do it but I'd rather have them
you can call it Federalists you can call
it the Constitution but I call it the
Constitution I would rather have them
make their decisions but he's made a lot
of good decisions and he hasn't said
he's going to but he's thinking about it
so I'll take a look at it's one of the
doctors that if you allow children back
in the schools you know wind up pose a
threat to spreading the virus even
further to some of those vulnerable I
think the answer is obvious but if you
want either would you want to just talk
about that maybe Tony
yeah I mean from from from fewer public
health issues is that if you have a
situation in which you don't have a real
good control over an outbreak and you
allow children to gather together they
likely will get infected and if they get
infected the likelihood that they will
bring the infection home so that's
really is a risk I don't know the
situation at all in any detail and then
not specifically speaking about Florida
I'm just speaking generically about what
happens when you have infections in the
community and you have a congregation of
people such as in classrooms that that's
a risk I guess you could clarify the
people under 25 can die as a result of
this I'm not sure
again I in the country okay let's do
that because I don't want to have to be
answering for a particular state yes
people under 25 have died of coronavirus
disease in the United States of America
if you reopen the country in May and
there's a new outbreak we're a spike in
infections are you open to the idea of
shutting the country down again
depending on the outbreak happened as
you know with a couple of countries you
know what I'm doing I'm watching other
countries in many cases they're ahead of
us from the standpoint that it attacked
them before us it hit them first and I'm
watching what's happening with respect
to certain other countries some of them
obvious some of them less obvious and
what they're doing and the success of
they're having and that's gonna play a
large part of the role I'm also we're
also setting up a Council of very very
great doctors and businesspeople we're
going to be announcing it on Tuesday of
some great people the task force is the
second beyond this is beyond economic
this is really I call it the opening our
country task force or opening our
country Council so we don't get it
confused with Mike's task force which
has done so great and we're gonna have
the great business leaders great doctors
we're gonna have a great group of people
we'll probably do it by teleconference
because we don't really want them
traveling in for their own purposes I
don't think it would look good also but
we don't want them traveling it
so we'll do teleconference we did one
the other day with the banks and it was
very successful to teleconference itself
and we'll be announcing names on Tuesday
who's on that and that'll play a role
but ultimately you have to make that
decision and then I'll have to make a
decision do we close a little area
that's a hot spot i I do say this Jim I
want to get it open as soon as possible
this country was meant to be open and
vibrant and great not where people are
you know staying and I would love to
open it
I'm not determined anything the facts
are going to determine what I do but we
do want to get the country open so
important so I have a task force I'll
have a council it's going to be
announced on Tuesday with names that you
have a lot of respect for a lot of great
names different businesses different
people
bipartisan I didn't even ask I mean
honestly I think it's bipartisan the one
thing I didn't ask a you Republican or a
Democrat hard to believe but I didn't
ask so it would be and I want their
views on what they think also very
important different parts of the country
because you go to the Midwest it's
different than perhaps the east coast or
the west coast or the west coast those
numbers are really pretty amazing on the
west coast very interesting so we're
going to be announcing that in a very
short well probably Tuesday government
officials in Latin American and
Caribbean nations have been saying that
US authorities are blocking the shipment
of PBE in certain cases and I'm
wondering if you can speak to that as
well are they doing we have a tremendous
force out there naval force and we're
blocking the shipment of drugs so maybe
what they're doing is stopping ships
that they want to look when I'm blocking
what we're doing is we're making sure we
don't want drugs in our country and
especially with the over 160 miles of
wall it's getting very hard to get
through the border they used to drive
right through the border like they owned
it and it's
way they did they could drive right they
had human trafficking they had all of a
sudden they have a powerful wall up and
they're not driving through that wall
that wall is stuff and it's also loaded
up with equipment cameras and sensors
and everything you can think of on top
of that we have drones flying back and
forth over it so so it's in very very
powerful it's a very powerful barrier
between Mexico and the United States a
lot of people though what they're doing
now is they're trying to come in through
the waterways whether it's the Gulf or
the ocean itself and what we're doing is
we're being very tough it would being
tough because of drugs and also human
trafficking and remember the human
trafficking is mostly females it's
mostly females it's horrible and what
we're seeing is horrible but you have a
big but we have a human trafficking
human trafficking problem worldwide the
likes of which you know you think of it
as an ancient thing it's not ancient
it's bigger now than it's ever been
before over the last 10 years because of
the internet the internet made human
trafficking to the extent that it is now
which is massive the internet the
internet made it so big so we are we
have a big naval force that's stopping
so maybe when you mentioned that maybe
their ships are getting caught but we
are we are stopping a lot of ships and
we're finding a lot of drugs yes thank
you sir on the additional money for
small thank you but that's okay first of
all business I apparently speak Treasury
secretary munitions speaking with with
the Democrats in Congress yeah are you
allowing you talking about the new all
yeah the new 250 billion dollars are you
willing to give in to the Democratic
demands for additional money for
hospital states and cities in that in
room round I'd rather have that be in
phase four I don't deny it I I think
it's fun but I think it should be in
phase four and I think we should have
infrastructure and I think we should
have a payroll tax moratorium because
that's something that over a period of
time the workers get you know sort of
semi immediately it's over that period
of time it starts immediately but it's
over a period of time
I mean there are a lot of people I'm one
of them that would have liked to have
seen the payroll tax cut as a permanent
cut but we should do the double edged
meaning business employee payroll tax
cut so we're talking about that and I'm
certainly okay with helping the states
and helping the hospitals I just think
because look the hospitals need help you
see what they've gone through and the
states need help some states in
particular need help they need big help
I'm willing to look at that very
strongly but I like looking at it and
phase for the 251 is actually the plan
is working out well the banks are
getting started with the distribution
they've taken thousands and thousands of
applications the numbers aren't even
believable the number of applications
they're swamped but Bank of America and
Wells Fargo and I guess City Citibank is
just now kicking in and also what
nobody's talking about the commercial
banks the the community banks everyone's
talking commercial banks the community
banks are doing tremendous volumes and
they're probably doing them faster from
what I understand I hear the community
banks frankly are the easiest ones in
terms of getting the money out so the
money is getting out the applications
are far beyond what we ever anticipated
and that's what we're good that's why
we're going cuz this is money that goes
essentially to the workers who we want
the businesses to hold on to their
workers because once they lose the
workers they're never opening again it's
not going to happen okay in the back leg
or in the wall from wall street journal'
I wonder if you could expand a little
bit on here like the form that Mexico
would take the reimbursements like what
form with that tape you simply add it to
the tab for the wall and you mentioned
and I was
question- well there's no real cost
because we're agreeing to produce a
little bit less so number one it's
staying in the ground you have it you
have it for another day it's actually
cheaper than storing it where you take
it out and you deliver it to a massive
well like the strategic reserves our
national strategic reserves where has to
be brought there and that's you know an
expensive process in itself but oil is
getting to a point where I mean there
are some areas some people would say the
water is more valuable than the oil you
never thought you're gonna see that you
never thought having covered I know you
cover it you never thought you'd be
seeing oil at $20 a barrel but how about
$10 a barrel that you never thought
you'd say so we are looking at it very
strongly there is no real cost
I was helping mix I want to help Mexico
out we have a great relationship with
Mexico great relationship with the
president I really like him a lot he's
been terrific to us in the border
because he stopped he stopped you don't
see the caravans coming up anymore you
don't see all the problems when I took
office it was unbelievable what was
going on and they are really they have
been helping us a lot and we've been
helping them a lot you know they make
product for us they sell it to us and
it's fine it's a good relationship it's
in some times it's a great relationship
so he could not have done any more than
that and I think there was political
reasons for that for him that other
other nations don't have they don't have
that you know the nations that we're
talking about the 22 other nations that
we're talking about they just don't have
that problem so it doesn't cost us
anything and yet it's very valuable we
will be reimbursed in the future maybe
in the near future maybe in the more
distant future but we'll be reimbursed
by Mexico in a certain way and it'll be
fine but we get Mexico over the hump now
with all of that being said that doesn't
mean the deals gonna happen anyway
because they still have a lot of
different states but this was one of the
stumbling blocks okay go ahead China and
some other countries
and particularly active scene as maybe
taking advantage of the u.s. during this
process during this period try and
particularly active in the South China
Sea got a carrier down obviously what's
your message to some of these
adversaries look the way I view it is
this China has taken advantage of the
United States for 30 years okay I
mentioned the World Trade Organization
China has taken advantage of us through
that and using rules that are unfair to
the United States and they should have
never been allowed to should have never
been allowed to happen when China joined
and was allowed to join under those
circumstances the World Trade
Organization that was a very bad day for
the United States because they had rules
and regulations that were far different
and far easier than our rules and
regulations plus they took advantage of
them down to the last and you know stun
and you study China and you know what I
mean they took advantage of them like
very few people would even think to take
advantage of them and again they are
considered right a developing nation we
are not considered a developing nation
they given advantages okay for many
years China has ripped off the United
States and then I came along and right
now as you know China's paying 25% and
we've taken in billions and billions and
billions of dollars in tariffs from
China and I know a lot of the people
kept saying oh no we're paying well
we're not paying you know countries are
different
not every countries China but China
would devalue their currency and they'd
also pour out money and they essentially
were paying most of those tariffs not us
and as you know we've taken in tens of
billions of dollars they targeted our
farmers but we took in so much money
that I was able to give back one year
was 12 billion one year was 16 billion I
was able to give back our farmers the
money that they were targeted hurt China
bought 12 billion and bought 16 billion
one year twelve one year 16 I was able
to give him back to 12 and then give him
back to 16 the farmers and they weren't
targeted and they're all in business now
we're doing it because they got targeted
in a
anyway now I'm going to be very
interested to see so we signed a deal
with China and under that deal they're
supposed to buy substantially in excess
of 200 billion dollars from us that's
not only farm product it's manufacturing
product it's lots of different things
they're gonna buy a lot I just want to
see if they live up to that deal I know
President Xi I would say he would live
up to the deal but remember this
I never took off the tariffs it's still
25% that's how big 25 percent of two
hundred and fifty billion dollars so for
the first time and you saw her also now
again I'm going before the virus it cuz
that's sort of like that's like let's
start all over again okay I can't tell
you that yet because that chapter hasn't
been written yet but go up a few weeks
ago the deficit with the United States
and China was coming way down nobody's
seen that nobody has ever seen that
before but the deficit has come way down
so now we start a new chapter and I can
only tell you if a smart person is
standing where I'm standing we're gonna
do very well with China and I think it's
I have to also say this I think our
relationship and having the relationship
I have with China is a good thing but
for the first time we're benefiting
instead of being the sucker that could
you know they've got taken advantage for
years nobody you know I said to China
how did this ever happen I got to know
him very well I said to him
representatives of China at the top
level you know who I'm talking about
I say how did this ever happen they
looked at me and they said but nobody
ever called us we didn't have a deal
it's not like we had a bad deal we had
worse we didn't have any deal at all
so they just took advantage think of it
500 billion dollar-a-year deficit not
500 millions a lot of money right it's
not everyone thinks I made a mistake
when I say 500 trillion know what you
mean 500 million I said 500 billion
dollar-a-year deficit with China for a
long time but it was 200 it was 300 was
400 was
five hundred five hundred and fifty six
million five hundred and seven five
hundred billion dollars plus but your
deficit with China now I'm charging them
tariffs and you know it's very
interesting a lot of people that don't
want to do that they all agreed because
China has taken advantage of this
country like nobody has ever taken we
have built China with the money we gave
them now I give them a lot of credit
okay I give them a lot of credit they
did it but you know what we made it a
hell of a lot easier we gave them a
fortune go ahead I won't ask you a
question and then ask a question come
out they've just developed those okay so
this question is from but according to
sources Boeing executives are still
planning around the playoffs so should
Boeing or any company accepts federal
aid to stay in business during these
pandemic and penalized for laying off
workers
yeah well the eight hasn't been given
yet but they will be asking in my
opinion they haven't even asked yet
Boeing is not asked for aid yet but I
think they probably will now at the same
time they do have to run a company you
know this isn't a great time to sell
aeroplanes so let's not kid ourselves
okay if you're a business person Boeing
makes airplanes they had a big problem
with one but they make the greatest
airplanes they make the best airplanes
in the world they had the problem with
one they got it too complex it becomes
so complex you have to be number one in
your class at MIT to be able to fly it
it's a mistake every two years they want
get more and more I mean they had great
success with the 737 the Boeing 737 then
all of a sudden they do the max and they
say let's make it more complicated let's
put on different engines let's do this
let's do that it was not exactly a good
decision bad decision
very bad horrible decision number one
human lives and number two Horrible's
what's happened to the company here's a
company from a business standpoint it
was like probably the greatest company
in the world in my opinion I think it
amounts to 1% of GDP some people say
it's a half I think it's one but here's
one of the greatest companies anywhere
there were maybe the greatest and boom
now on top of what happened there with
the two planes and they say they have
that fix that's good they say it have it
fixed undisputably in fact somebody said
they gave me something I said you should
say it that way they said sir this is
now the safest airplane in the air I
said that's what you should say that's a
very good statement it's the safest
airplane in the air that's a very good
statement you should use it I said by
the way you're changing the name but
whether you do or not you should use
that but he said that a Boeing person
said to me it's the safest airplane in
the air that's a great thing but we know
they're gonna need help now does that
mean they're gonna need help and they
should keep people that they absolutely
don't need that business is a very
cyclical business like many businesses
frankly so that determination hasn't
made they have not spoken to us yet I
think they will be maybe they won't need
help that'll be great
look Boeing made so much money who would
have there who would have thought they
could have made all of those planes that
are parked all over the place in many
cases I guess payments not made but who
would have thought they could do that
and they're still a solvent company okay
I mean what a tragic thing happened in
numerous ways but also economically so
when they see us making sure that Boeing
is strong again is very very powerful
and very important and we'll do whatever
is necessary to do please
like a quick one and then a longer one
I'm first of all happy - should we keep
this going everybody wants to keep it
going for a while yes we have time if
you want you like you're not gonna
criticize me that the conference was too
long you know if I leave short yesterday
left sure it was too short if I stayed
too long they said was too long
someday we're gonna get it just right
okay should we continue should we
continue
Johnson CK I have not no I I have a call
just to wish him well to his to his
group no I don't want to be calling him
now I want him to get better he's a
great guy he's become a friend of mine
real friend of mine you know he has a
great feeling for our country for
obviously for his country he loves it
he's he's a tremendous guy he's become I
think he's probably right now he was
very high just sir I think he might be a
hundred percent popularity right now I
think he's you know when they talk about
approval polls right yeah we hear that
term I'm sure you never heard that I
hear it all the time his approval rating
must be about 300% but he's a he's a
great guy he was a great guy before and
I think people see what he's been
through what he's been through is
incredible and they say a big turn so
let's see what happens let's hope and if
I may where do you see the use of
something like immunity certificates or
documents or passports when we get to
enter something like issues immunity
certificates once we get to antibody
testing whether this will be useful way
well I see a lot of yeah I see a lot of
different things we're going to be very
careful for who comes into the country
look my opposition party wants to have
open borders this is a case where I'm
very glad that my position is I don't
want open borders I want very strong
borders that includes not only on the
southern border our southern border with
Mexico and you could also say our
northern border with Canada but we want
to have strong borders and I think this
is maybe one of the learning points we
learned something about
borders we need borders the country
needs borders to be a great country and
this is I think this is a great point go
ahead you have something else I wasn't
just thinking about for borders I just
thought for ordinary Americans who are
currently stuck at home if they test
different bodies they did it turns out
they've had the disease and therefore
shouldn't be infected again some sort of
documentation that would allow them to
go back to work safely you mean once
they get better they have the disease
and they're better and they have the
immunity now they they have supposedly
according to what I'm hearing it could
be for a long period could be for a
lifetime it could also be for a year or
two I'm hearing Tony so nobody has told
me yet if it's for a year if it's for
two years or if it's for a lifetime like
chickenpox they say if you have
chickenpox you have immunity
they say for a lifetime I hope that's
true but but nobody's actually told me
with certainty maybe because they don't
know yet you don't know yet
because it's new you know this came upon
us nobody knew we just we just they do
know you have it for a period of time
and it's strong for a period of time
they don't know that's hence the
antibodies that were making I saw
somebody was really sick and he got
better a young person relatively young
person 35 and physically fit you know
and he he got better he made it barely
but he made it his first thing that he
did when he was better I want to give I
want to give whatever I can give to help
other people because nobody should go
through it's a tough it's a tough thing
so we don't know yet how long if you'd
like to add anything to them but we
don't know yet if it is it a year it
will be a year but is it more than a
year and only time is going to tell okay
thank you will you have
on the open the country council we
talked about yeah I think so I think
we're gonna put some governor's I've
gained great respect for governor's both
Republican and Democrat I've actually
become friends with some of the Democrat
governors that I wouldn't have really
had the privilege of getting to know and
governor Murphy of New Jersey's very
liberal guy I'm not but we've had a
great relationship John Bell as you know
I call him John Bell but John bel
Edwards people call him John Bell sort
of a cool name from Louisiana I have a
very good relationship with him a Gavin
Newsom honestly I think we've fight
everything we're fighting right now I
want automobiles to be made cheaper and
safer and stronger and but you save
three four thousand dollars per or and
environmentally equal we're better maybe
and we're fighting on that we're
fighting a lot of different things we
fight on the border he wants open
borders I want I want people to come
into our country illegally but I've
gotten very friendly with Gavin Newsom
he's done a very good job here
I think I've gotten very friendly I mean
he's been I think sort of a friend of
mine for a long time don't get to see
him much but Governor Cuomo of New York
would talk all the time I told you I
spoke from literally the last call just
before walking in here I've gotten to
I've really developed a lot of good
friendships with the governors and
including the governors I think Mike
DeWine Republican but I think he's done
a great job in Ohio so yeah I want to
put on both parties I'd want to have
some governors I'm not gonna have all of
the governors but I'd like to put some
representative governor's on the council
yes I would like to do a couple of them
they've all said yes so far everyone
said yes I think everybody would like to
be on that council that's a very
important council
by me do you have a message to those
pastors who are still planning to have
Easter services defying the public
health guidelines well see you're gonna
have to say it louder to those what
those Buster's who are still planning to
have pastors or the pastors I didn't
understand your word okay you have a
very nice voice but it's a little bit
low and you're far back I've had talks
with the pastors and most of the
pastor's agree and it's very complex
subject let's face it you know for the
obvious reasons I don't have to go into
and most of the pastor's agree that they
are better off doing what they're doing
which is distancing they feel that let's
get this over with and they want to get
back to church so badly I mean can you
imagine we have Easter Sunday and I'm
gonna be watching pastor Robert Jeffress
there's been a great guy did I tell you
he's been a great guy and I'm gonna be
watching on a laptop now a laptop is not
the same as being in his church or being
in another church it's not it no matter
what you say you don't get say oh isn't
it wonderful
but I've done this for three weeks and
they've had tremendous I let people know
who it is they've had the biggest
audiences they've ever had they have
millions of people now watching and
people are really liking what they're
hearing so I'm gonna be with on Easter
pastor I don't even know if he knows it
yet but he will soon I think you will in
about two minutes pastor Robert Jeffress
and he's a terrific guy a terrific man
I've gotten to know him very well he's a
man of great compassion he loves our
country and I'm gonna be with him on
Easter meeting I'm gonna be with him
watching on a laptop doesn't sound good
but it's you know it's one of those
things it cannot be Church you know I'm
not going to get into it it cannot be
Church most pastors and most people you
know a faith people that we listen to
and respect and admire Franklin Graham
is a person I have great respect for
most people and who's done an incredible
job in New York on Central Park where
they put up Samaritan's Purse he's done
an incredible job
the son of the late great Billy Graham
his family is incredible he's incredible
Franklin Graham the job he's doing on I
mean he loves to do it
he has such a passion and that's why
he's so good at it he does it with with
incredible love and he will tell you
we're all saying we've got to get our
country cured I know there are some
pastors and ministers and others that
want to get together I would and I have
great respect for him two of them I know
but I would say first heal I'm a
Christian heal our country
let's get healed before we do this and
this time to do that will do it for
hopefully the rest of our lives please
the mercy and the comfort seem to be
underutilized is there any consideration
either to sending the medical units into
the cities to help hospitals there were
sent when projections were much higher
then I say Tony backed it up Deborah's
made the statement they said you're not
gonna need these many rooms but we
wanted to be prepared I mean you know we
had the ship they did an incredible job
with the the comfort was supposed to be
in maintenance for a period of four
weeks and they had it done in three and
a half four days and it came up and so
we had it there if there was a disaster
from the standpoint of you needed all of
the I tell you the Javits Center
Andrew will tell you we were ready to go
it's incredible the job they did but
they're they're using less beds this is
a good thing not a bad thing they're
using less Spence
now Javits has been pretty busy over the
last couple of days and the death
numbers are horrific but you go back now
and you're finding they're gonna start
to come down very substantially it's
just based on the fact that the bed
usage the number of beds are much much
less much much less so the mercy and the
comfort were there in case they needed
them
Los Angeles where you have the one in
New York we have the other they just
don't fortunately we haven't hit numbers
where they would have knit they would
have been used they're always gonna be
sort of overflow because they're on the
edges you know they're they're not as
convenient as certain places but the the
people were ready willing and able they
were ready to go they're gonna do a
great job but fortunately we don't need
just like we didn't need as many
ventilators when they were asking in New
York for 40,000 ventilators I had
experts these people I listen to them
they said you'll never need that many
and they were right in New York now as
it's and I dealt really well with mayor
de Blasio we got him a lot of
ventilators we got into a lot of
ventilators but we never felt you needed
the numbers that you were talking about
and we were right on that now with all
of that being said we have a lot of
ventilators ready to go we have almost
10,000 in to stockpile that 10,000 can
move rapidly we can be within 24 hours
almost anywhere and hopefully we're not
gonna have to be but it's just it's
really this has been a great military
operation it hasn't all been military
because we're dealing with great
companies would have companies that are
making masks with and we're all set up
in the mass to I just told you we have
an order coming in soon
500 million masks 500 million we have
companies you know the story with GM or
3m also GM but 3m is doing a great job I
spoke to the CEO the other day we
settled it out we had a dispute with
them and it's now well settled and I
think they're trying to show the country
something maybe me but the country
something so we've done you know I think
and not me I'm not not talking about
this country our country the people that
are doing it Army Corps of Engineers
FEMA these people sitting right here
people that we have in the back that are
watching every word that we're saying
they've done a fantastic job they really
have done a fantastic job please
president I wanted to ask you a question
about testing you've mentioned the
impossibility of testing the entire
American public so has what do we have
the Surgeon General
what do we have 350 million people
you're gonna do that not what I'm
getting at what I'm getting at is
priorities and dr. Burks has mentioned
how there had been priorities and
certain regional parts of the country
and I wanted to ask you specifically
about the one industry in particular and
that's food processing plants is there a
priority to get testing at food
processing plants all across the country
well you're asking that because of what
happened it's a fair question to what
happened in Denver because in Denver
I've never seen I said what's going on
we're looking at this graph where
everything's looking beautiful and it's
coming down and then you got this one
spike its I said what happened to Denver
and many people very quickly and by the
way they were on it like so fast you
wouldn't believe it they knew every
aspect they have people going not only
testing who did you see
where were you how many people did you
meet were you out to dinner in somebody
else's home where were you where did
that where did this number of people
come from how did they are totally on it
now this just happened I just saw it
this morning I'm looking at everything
smooth going down topping out then you
have this one spike in Denver it's like
where did this come from so we'll be
looking at that and and we don't want
cases like that happening this was but
this is the kind of thing can happen
this is very complex it's a very
brilliant enemy you know it's a
brilliant enemy they develop drugs like
the antibiotics you see it antibiotics
used to solve every problem now one of
the biggest problems the world has is
the germ has gotten so brilliant that
the antibiotic can't keep up with it and
they're constantly trying to come up
with a new people go to a hospital and
they catch they go for a heart operation
that's no problem but they end up dying
from from problems you know the problems
I'm talking about if there's a whole
genius to it
we're fighting not only is it hidden but
it's very smart okay
it's invisible and it's hidden but it's
it's very smart and you see that in a
case like a denver but you know i think
we're doing well and and there on denver
like you wouldn't believe i came in this
morning it was a flurry i said what's
going on they said denver so what
happened at denver cuz denver was doing
pretty well and they've got that under
control but yeah that would be a case
where you do some very big testing peter
mr. president we learned that more than
16 million americans filed for
unemployment over the past three weeks
it's Good Friday it's payday we were
seeing troubling paralyzing lines at
food banks around the country what are
you saying to those Americans in need
right this moment number one I love them
number two we're working really hard it
wasn't their fault what happened
sometimes they don't do a good job and
they lose their job that's one thing
this is a case where we take the
strongest economy in the history of the
world which is what we had more people
working in the United States Peter then
ever before almost I mean look at the
numbers 160 million people almost just
short of 160 excuse me so we have the
greatest economy we've ever had by the
way black unemployment Hispanic
unemployment Asian unemployment the best
numbers we've ever had in virtually
every way and then you get hit like this
and it's traumatic people that had great
jobs that went out to dinner and they
didn't have any problems that take their
family they were making good salaries
all of a sudden you know you use the
term cold turkey it's cold turkey they
go from that to having no money and
waiting for their checks which are being
processed very rapidly but they still
they have to go out and look for money
it's a terrible thing all I say is we
love them we're working so hard and
they're gonna be back and I hope they're
gonna be back even stronger than before
I can't just to follow up then you chose
not to do a national stay-at-home order
now that you say you want to reopen
parts of the economy what authority do
you have to do that is that ultimately
up to the states to do that no it's
really the states can do things if they
want I can override it if I want but the
National stay at home just so you
understand 95% of the country is stay at
home like as an example I was speaking
with the great governor of Texas Greg
Abbott the other day he has a stay at
home a lot of people didn't even know it
but he had to stay at home some people
reported Texas was and he had a very
strong actually a very strong stay at
home 95 to 96 percent the South Carolina
as you know has it which at one point a
week ago they didn't have South Carolina
another great governor mcmaster know 95%
of the country is covered now the states
that aren't and again constitutionally
from a federalist standpoint if I
thought there was a problem if I saw a
state with a problem I would absolutely
demand it but they're doing great and
the states that aren't our state said
have not had a big problem right now I
want to use it I would rather have the
states use it I would rather and this is
so shocking for me a lot of people
saying wow he's really very recent isn't
he a lot of people are shocked they
think I do it I have absolute authority
to use it but so far our relationship
with governor's and the job they're
doing I haven't had to do it would I do
it if I saw a state that was out of
control and they didn't have to stay at
home policy I would do it in a heartbeat
somebody said it's totally up to the
president I saw this point it's totally
up and it is I don't know that I've had
a bigger decision but I'm gonna surround
myself with the greatest minds not only
the greatest minds but the greatest
minds in numerous different businesses
including the business of politics and
reason and we're gonna make a decision
and hopefully it's going to be the right
decision I will say this I want to get
it open as soon as we can we have to get
our country open Jeff say sir what
metrics you will use to make that the
metrics right here that's my metrics
that's all I can do I can listen to 35
people at the end I've got to make a
decision and I didn't think of it until
yesterday I said you know this is a big
decision but I want to be guided I'm
gonna be guided by them I'm gonna be
guided by our vice-president I'm gonna
make a decision based on a lot of
different opinions some will maybe
disagree and some I'd love to see it
where they don't disagree will they be
risked it's always going to be a risk
that something can flare up there's
always gonna look look at what's
happening where countries are trying to
get open and there's a flare up and
they'll go but I'd like to flare up to
be very localized so that we can control
it from a local standpoint without
having to close it so there's always a
risk this is if this is genius that
we're fighting you know we're fighting
this hidden enemy which is genius okay
it's genius the way it's attacked for so
many countries and so many different
angles and I mean you take a look at
what's going on and the greatest doctors
in the world I think they're close by
the way but they haven't figured it out
yet look what it's done to some people I
mean some people it's grabbed and it's a
it's a horrible it's a horrible way to
go you want to know the truth it's a
horrible and then other people it hardly
has an impact on we talked about it
sniffles it's less they don't even know
they had anything and some people I
looked at New York this morning and I
look at what's happening and the amount
of people that are dying and dying
violently dying it's it's a it's a very
tough adversary
but we're gonna win and we're gonna win
it we're gonna win it very decisively
I'm going to have to make a decision and
I only hope to god that it's the right
decision
but I would say without question it's
the biggest decision I've ever had to
make the models I understand them are
based on social distancing continuing
through May is that correct
and if you were to open the economy on
May 1st or sometime during that month
would that impact the models in terms of
the deaths that you expect so the model
the IHM e model does state that it's
through May every month we've had these
model discussions haven't we for weeks
now so the models are informed by the
data and you can see how much that model
has shifted on the amazing work of the
American people so I think that's what
we're evaluating right now remember when
when I talked yesterday I've been in
public health a long time I have never
except for Ebola where we worked very
closely with the communities about
specific issues we've never taken a
country wide or a global wide approach
to mitigation this is unprecedented I
will tell you there is nothing in the
literature about specifically what to
expect and I think that's why the models
continue to modify themselves based on
what actually has happened with social
distancing and hand-washing
and all of the pieces that the American
people are doing the decreasing the
closing of the bars the closing of the
restaurants no communal eating that was
thought to be a very big issue and many
of the other cultures that went through
this virus so the models continue to
evolve based on the impact and so
therefore it makes it very difficult to
interpret each component of social
distancing and which ones are
absolutely critical now there's a way to
do that in a multivariate analysis
potentially and I want to I want
everyone to understand there are states
that are tested there are states that
are doing contact tracing so I mean it's
I think sometimes we get you know we
look at what New York is doing and
Detroit we forget that there's a Utah
and New Mexico and a North and South
Dakota and a whole series of states that
have been doing testing and contact
tracing and have been testing it rates
higher than that per capita rate that we
all have discussed so we're looking at
that what did they do
where are the most vulnerabilities where
are the outbreaks most likely to occur
that's why I've been talking about
nursing homes because we do believe that
there's a relationship between age and
seriousness of disease not to say that
there can't be young people with serious
disease but proportionally it's a
smaller piece with serious disease and
so when you have that kind of spectrum
where the older and the more complicated
the higher the severity you get the
impression that there may be more
asymptomatic in younger age groups and
that's where the antibody test comes in
so when you put all these pieces
together you're trying to understand
where is where would be the first
signals so we have surveillance out
there right now with the CDC's influenza
like illness I hope you're all tracking
that it is showing these small changes I
think we can believe in that is their
surveillance tool married with their
syndromic piece giving us the insight
about where to test and then where to
proactively test in nursing homes and
other vulnerable groups because that has
been the signal in a series of the
states that have very very low
prevalence and incidence of disease so
that's the kind of factors we're putting
all together to really define the best
way forward and we have superb roadmaps
I hope you all have seen them there's
been about six different roadmaps to
opening but people have put online and
again there's no literature that you can
cite and said well we did this 20 years
ago and what really worked there's there
isn't that there's brilliant public
health people giving us their insight
or the question is because those are the
models you've been using if you do go
with opening up starting to open up the
economy again I'm a first doesn't that
lead to more dense well look at how much
it changed with mitigation and now we're
looking at those state by state and
there's some states in there that are
still in contact tracing so we're
looking at the impact of that model and
what that model predicted based on the
type of contact tracing less mitigation
more contact raising are we are you
getting what I'm talking about okay so
there are states that didn't
stay-at-home orders but we're doing
contract rate contact tracing from
outbreak so we're looking at them and
how they have done and we're looking at
certainly what's happened in the big
metro areas and we're integrating all of
that data together to make a plan going
forward so I can't tell you because look
at how much the model has changed in
just a week remember just a week ago it
was 80,000 now it's 60,000 so and the
curves I'm sure you're all watching it
the curves of getting much broader
confidence intervals there is still the
dotted line but the confidence intervals
around the dotted line are getting
bigger when you see that you know the
model has a bit of an instability and so
that's why Tony and I based a lot of our
decision and discussion on cases and
what physically is happening in that
county in that state at the same time
not ignoring the models but integrating
the models is one piece of our thought
process do you want to come up here and
say what you think about my I just I
just want to say that you know you
talked about couldn't it lead to death
meaning you open up could lead to death
and you're right but you know what
staying at home leads to death also and
it's very traumatic for this country but
staying at home if you look at numbers
that leads to a different kind of death
perhaps but it leads to death also so
it's a very big decision as I say it's
the biggest decision I'll ever make
alright we'll do a couple more we'll go
Thank You mr. president um before you
came out here you said one of the last
people that you talked to was Governor
Cuomo and at his news conference today
he said that he was asking you to use
the defense production act to require
companies to make more tests to
streamline testing is that something
that you would consider because you've
considered it with ventilators you know
the other side seems to keep using that
and I have used it you know I've enacted
it you do know and I've used it some
people thought viciously just ask a
couple of companies if you want you can
just look up the names and I'm surprised
that he would have said that we actually
have great tests we have others under
development
you don't need full testing as the
doctors have been talking about ad
nauseam so I would be surprised that he
would have said that meaning it that way
if he if he did I'd have a much
different type answer go ahead we talked
about testing yeah we did talk about
testing and one of the things I did was
I put the two doctors in charge of that
call I said you know what Andrew they
have two very talented people standing
here we're getting ready to go on let me
put them and let me have them talk to
you and they talked to him really at
length and I think by the time they
finished he understood what he was what
we were saying he understood it very
clearly you've talked a lot this week
about holding the World Health
Organization responsible for its
response to the corona virus I'm curious
if you've given any more thought to
holding China financially responsible
for the part that it played and the
economic toll that it's taking on the
American people yeah I understand the
question very well nobody has done to
China or treated China as strongly as I
have use the word strongly as you know
you've reported on it billions and
billions of dollars is flowing into our
treasury because of what i've done with
china i think it's a very sad thing that
happened and i think if people knew
including the World Health Organization
and I do believe they knew but they
didn't want to tell the world and we're
gonna get to the bottom of it and we'll
have reports on all of this and we are
we are not happy about it but I wanted
to leave the world health for later and
I can tell you that we're constantly in
touch with China we're talking to China
and we've expressed how we felt we're
not happy about it we're not happy about
it at all Kristen okay one or two more
yeah this president we hear from a lot
of people who see these briefings as
sort of happy talk briefings and some of
the officials paint a rosy picture of
what is happening around the country if
you look at some of these questions do
we have enough mass know we have enough
tests know do we have enough PPE no yes
I think the answer is yes who said no to
that I'm saying there's a no you're
saying no but whose yeah yeah but your
ask but do we have enough mass yes you
said do we have masks yes do we have
enough tests yes plus we're developing
new - do we have enough do we have
enough ventilators yes do we have enough
hospital beds yes we've built 20,000
hospital beds we have enough hospital
beds go ahead Jim let's go what do you
say - you mean you watch the coverage
you know nice a lot of cover a lot of it
just when the doctors depending on your
air they always say that because
otherwise you're not going to put them
on let me just taste them the governors
have said last night they had a group of
Governors 14 governors they were
together someplace and they said it's
been unbelievable
what's happened we've been totally
responsive ventilators everyone has the
ventilators they need to a point where
we're getting calls from foreign
countries saying you have all the
ventilators can we get some canned we're
going to try and help some of these
countries these people have done an
incredible job this is not happy talk
maybe it's happy tough for you it's not
happy talk for me we're talking about
death we're talking about the greatest
economy and the war
one day I have to close it off and we
did the right thing because maybe it
would have been 2 million people died
instead of whatever that final number
will be which could be 60 could be 7 it
could be 75 could be 55 thousands of
people of that there's nothing happy
about it Jim this is sad talk this is
the saddest these are the saddest these
are the saddest news conferences that
I've ever had I don't like doing them
you know why because I'm talking about
death I'm talking about taking the
greatest economy ever created we had the
greatest numbers we've ever had in
almost every aspect of of economics from
employment to companies that look at the
airlines they were having the best year
now all of a sudden we have to save them
ok there's no happy talk to him
this is the real deal and I've got to
make the biggest decision of my life and
I've only started thinking about that I
mean you know I've made a lot of big
decisions over my life you understand
that this is by far the biggest decision
of my life because I have to say ok
let's go this is what we learn is where
you have figures but do you have many
doctors that say unbelievable job I
watched this morning and I watched a
certain network and it wasn't Fox and
you a doctor saying that we've done an
incredible job you just read off these
no no no well we have ventilators we
have equipment we have beds
how about beds I mean Governor Cuomo
just told me a little while ago he's got
plenty of beds in fact I have a hard
time filling Javits Center we built them
two thousand nine hundred beds so that's
not a fair question you're stabilizing
just talking about region excuse me we
have masks we have everything and we
were trying to get ready for the surge
and a lot of people said it will never
happen Deborah said it you'll never need
that many beds they said we needed
40,000 ventilators 40 thousands like
building a car 40,000 ventilators people
said I felt it too you'll never need
that many guess what we have tremendous
we have with the envy of the world in
terms of
laterz Germany would like some France
would like some we're gonna help
countries out a Spain needs him
desperately Italy needs him desperately
Mexico needs him desperately he asked me
last night would it be possible to get
10,000 ventilators within a short period
of time I'll be able to help out Mexico
no Jim just the opposite of your
question it's not no no no it's yes yes
yes we're in great shape and you know
what what's happening now is those
numbers are horrible but take a look at
the number of beds we have beds
available all over new york new york
really being the epicenter new york new
york has experienced something that has
been absolutely horrific
I saw Hart's island yesterday I saw
those people being buried yesterday
fortunately we have the beds and you can
speak to mayor de Blasio you can speak
to Governor Cuomo people are people
can't even believe the job we've done
they can't even believe it and I give
tremendous credit to the military
there's been a military operation with
private people wait a minute wait wait
I give tremendous credit to our military
to the Army Corps of Engineers to FEMA
to these people the job they've done is
incredible and you shouldn't be asking
for that kind of a question Jim honest
the country good you shouldn't be asking
that kind of a question you should say
you know what it's been really
incredible what's been a half an hour
Jim nobody's asking what governor let me
ask you this what governor we have more
tests than anybody in the world we have
everything we have virtually every
country in the world calling us asking
us how do we get these tests that you
have your testing is the best in the
world how do we get it they've done a
fantastic job and when you ask a
question like that it's very insulting
to a lot of great people okay one more
place you may have seen how Sweden has
responded to the
the schools are open bars and
restaurants are open Suite is different
do you do you regret not following that
approach is that approach work I did we
could have followed that approach and if
we did follow that approach I think we
might have two million people dead and
Sweden is having a lot of difficulty you
know look I'm very friendly with the
leadership in Sweden they took a
different approach they're a very
disciplined country to start off with
but they did take a different and you
know other places tried it UK tried it
the herd approach okay heard and they
tried it and you saw what happened in UK
it set him back a lot a lot of time it's
been you know they having a tough time
other countries have tried it and Sweden
is suffering greatly
I mean Sweden's suffering greatly if we
did the herd if we went with the herd as
they say we would have had potentially I
mean you see that the charts nobody
knows nobody will ever know fortunately
because we're gonna be substantially
less than the minimum
I certainly hope unless something
happens that would be tragic so they had
a minimum number if we did if one of the
reasons we're so far below that numbers
because nobody thought the American
people could be so disciplined nobody
thought it was possible and I guess when
they watched us appear every day and
they watched other people and they
listened to their representatives and
governors nobody thought that the
American people could be so disciplined
they've been unbelievable and because of
that so you have a minimum number of a
hundred thousand and then you had the
2.2 number that if we did nothing if we
did just kept working and everybody go
to work people would be dropping dead on
the subways no if we would have lost a
million people take the 2.2 million and
cut it in half make it cut it in more
than him make it a million people okay
now take that number and cut it in half
make it 500,000 people
that's if we did nothing right it's
unacceptable that's too many people so
we have we spent more money on stimulus
who cares by comparison you take 2.2 you
cut it in half you cut it in half you
cut it in if you keep cutting it in half
I don't care what nobody choose five
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
well we're gonna have we were talking
fifty sixty sixty-five maybe maybe but
if we would have done what one country
tried and it has been very tough for
them you know that very very nasty very
tough but if we would have done that
here and again you got to remember UK
tried it and I was a little surprised
and I watch it they were going about
what two weeks and they said we got a
stop because it was then we're gonna
have a whole country infected so with
all of that being said we got to get
back to work we got to get we got to get
our country open but we could have lost
two million people we could have lost 1
million people we could have lost a half
a million people if we would have lost
500,000 people
now I'll say this also from the
standpoint of being president and vice
president and we're up there and we're
doing that hurt and we're gonna bullet
through it do you honestly think people
like Jim and yourself and other people
would have Jeff would have put up with
it as people are dying all over they
would have said this man is crazy
because the numbers Tony at a minimum
would have been many many times greater
than the numbers were talking about so
I'm very honored by our decisions all of
us we talk about it all the time I said
you want to let him just you just write
it you just write it right through we
would have lost potentially millions of
people now it would have been
unsustainable it would have been
impossible to do and the American people
have been so disciplined it's been my
honor to be their president I've said it
before I'll say it again I'll say it
always it's been it's been my great
honor to have been their president and I
have a big decision coming up and I only
hope to god that it's the right decision
but it'll be based on the input from a
lot of very talented talented people
very smart people and people that love
our country thank you
all very much thank you